any challenge of established scientific
dogma
is labeled pseudoscience isn't that a
bit arrogant
i mean isn't pseudoscience only
pseudoscience until it's
actual science kepler and copernicus
were ridiculed by their peers
louis pasteur's research was rejected by
the medical establishment
gregor mendel nikola tesla initially
they were rejected
imagine the hate they'd get if twitter
existed but
that's a long time ago surely we've
matured since then
think about this in 1903 when the wright
brothers and others were building
airplanes
the new york times said manned flight
would not be possible for 1 to 10
million years oops and in 1985
the new york times said no matter how
inexpensive or powerful a laptop
computer would become
nobody would want one no boy and when
apple announced the iphone
the time said they'd probably never
build it and even if they did
nobody would buy it and speaking of
twitter
here's what the new york times said when
it launched using
twitter for literate communication is
about as likely as
firing up a cb radio and hearing some
guy recite the iliad
whether the service could be made into a
sustainable business
quite unknown i'm skeptical
haven't i always told you don't trust
the media you have
if you suggest that levitating heavy
objects with sound
or creating free energy is even possible
you're viciously attacked
not just by facebook and twitter but by
the new york freaking times
aren't new ideas worth exploring did
steve jobs care what people thought
about him
does elon musk care no they just went
out and changed the world
so my message today is not to the
corporate media or social media
they make money by getting all of us to
attack each other that's their business
model
it's shameful and that's why nobody
trusts them who cares
george bernard shaw said all great
truths begin as blasphemies
this message is to those blasphemers to
the recluse out there building castles
with sound
and magnets and his own hands to the
nerd in the garage tinkering with
electronics because he knows in his
heart
there is a better way this message is to
the next kepler
jobs elon musk to the misfits and
dreamers and visionaries my message is
to you
they are going to attack you they are
going to hate you
ignore them keep dreaming keep building
keep blaspheming because i can tell you
with 100
certainty the world needs you
much more than it needs the new york
[Music]
times